based on the dark brooding comic that
became a children's cartoon that became
the worst musical tour of all time comes
a 90s movie that proves the turtle
franchise was ridiculous way before
Michael Bay got his hands on it in stone
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles - the
secret of the is the man in creepy
rubber turtle suits are back in the hit
sequel that held up much better when you
were a kid
featuring cheesy fight sequences
outdated 90s references corny freeze
frames and bad cosplay shredder I guess
it looks better than ugly CGI yeah your
favorite turtles have returned to kick
some shell but this time due to stupid
parent complaints about the first movie
watch as their iconic weapons stay glued
into their holsters and instead see them
fight with belts yo-yos ties blankets
soft nerf bats sausages Gaga and words
come on just stab somebody already get
ready to hang ten with these four overly
large trained ninjas who are terrible at
hiding Oh being silent or sneaking
around
oh did they get stuck in a net she would
be great if they could use their swords
or something I mean come on he's got it
right there this back what are they
doing in a world full of cartoon
characters and action figures you loved
spend more time with these human
characters you don't like keno and
obnoxious little twerp
rayvon what I do I'll dream with
something a little thinner this boring
science guy and this completely random
lady who calls herself April O'Neill did
the people who made this even like the
cartoon where's Krang / Baxter so bogus
the shredder has returned and returned
and returned and he probably smells like
now watch him strike fear into the
hearts of men with his ability to stand
and do nothing while his enemies are
right in front of him and his lieutenant
Tatsu who also stands and does nothing
while his enemies are right in front of
him together they'll recruit a city and
explicably filled with martial arts
trained teenage runaways who vastly
outnumber our heroes yet can't ever seem
to take out four slow dudes in huge
rubber turtle suits
why are they dancing tremble as they
battle for control of the secret of the
ooze which is never really explained now
that I mention it but for some reason
can turn Turtles into Ninja Turtles turn
flowers into bigger flowers and turn
bebop and Rocksteady and a to lame-ass
ripoffs that no one ever asked for
Oh
are so gear up for a kid's action flick
so terrified to show any fun ninja
action its climax consists of taking out
the shredder with a guitar solo taking
out the super shredder with a bridge
collapsing on itself and a vanilla ice
concert when do they have time to
coordinate this stop dancing with
vanilla ice stop it what are you doing
no tangent no need to know starring the
Blue Ranger wreck-it Ralph
Bart Simpson nerd Otello ratna's never
clean surf ninja Asian Darth Vader
April's mom and Justin Bieber's dad
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles - the
secret of the ooze
so parents were mad about them using
their weapons but totally okay with them
advocating an all Pizza diet hypocrites
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
press fart to continue
you've cat to be kidding me right now we
need to stop manbearpig i'm super-cereal
now i am become death the destroyer of
worlds and they were rescued by a--
let's say moe